I have long hair again, and not because I'm sad.
Bangs are usually a sign of sadness,
extensions are a sign of just boredom.
Announcement! I've decided that for the month of November, I'm gonna be making 5 videos a week.
Monday through Friday like I used to do a while ago,
and I guess I'm gonna start doing now.
That means asterisk, I will try my best
to make 5 videos a week, Monday through Friday.
A lot of people do vlogmas or Vlogtober, things like that and I don't really do those.
So I've arbitrarily decided that for the month of November I will be committing to 5 videos a week.
It's kind of a means to hopefully get
some creative juices flowing,
to hopefully get you guys excited about
this channel again.
And you can expect regular videos,
and I don't know, this might be terrible, it might be great.
It will likely be terrible and we'll repress it really deep down
at the end of the month, but hey, it's going to happen.
And you would think that if I had planned this, I would have planned any
ideas or videos or stuff for this and I haven't!
My plan is that the
anxiety associated with the social accountability of announcing this type of thing-
Makes me do it. On top of that
I thought I would categorize each day of the week,
so you can start to know what you're gonna expect for the month of November.
Here's how it breaks down: F*ck it Monday: sexy related videos to get your Monday
grumpiness off to a
pervy start. Didn't think through any of the descriptions of this.
Tuesday Screws-day! Sounds a lot like F*ck It Mondays when I say it out loud,
but it's not! It's just videos where I screw around in one way or another.
Q & Wednesday! Wednesdays will be Q&As and/or advice related videos.
Thurs-DIY! Just maybe how to's and DIYs on Thursday. And Fridays will be Fri-diary
and/or commenting on comments. You saw in my last video, if you watched it,
my vlogging camera fell into a lake and so it currently doesn't work so it might be commenting on comments
this Friday, and then once I get a new camera
we might get back to Fri-diary... who knows! These are established days of the week,
but I'm allowed at any point to veer from the establishment because I make the rules.
Please subscribe. So that's what's happening this month! Get excited.
That's the big announcement
And then I thought because it's Wednesday we would start off with a Q and Wednesday.
I went on Twitter and asked you guys what you needed advice on and a hashtag: great grace advice.
So let's just jump right into it.
"My partner broke up with me on Halloween, my birthday is tomorrow.
Which wine pairs nicely with Twix and tears?"
All of the wine.
And then you can recycle the bottle by breaking it over your ex-partner's car and slashing the tires with it.
I don't advocate that. I'm just saying.
"How to write a 30 page thesis without pulling your hair out"
Shave your head.
"How do I get out of this non-metaphorical box?"
In my experience, you gotta f*ck your way out of it.
"How do you handle stress?" I manhandle it.
I door handle it.
I show it the door. Both bad.
"How to politely leave a party/social event without being rude?"
Just start incorporating in conversations to people
that you're an actual ghost. Then you don't have to feel rude about leaving,
people will probably...ask you to leave.
"How do I stop procrastinating so much?"
Try amateur-crasting!
It's only gonna get worse this month.
"Do you think if I clickbait my resume cover letter with, say, 'best resume ever', I'll get more interviews?"
No, you gotta clickbait it with "Former
David Dobrik" assistant,
parentheses: emotional.
"How do I look at the sun without hurting my eyes?"
I don't have children, but I can imagine
looking directly at your own spawn
is disgusting so. It might just be a feeling that doesn't go away
"I need to lose about 25 kilograms by June/July. Help a brother out?
Thanks in advance, dawg. Speaking of, says hi to Goose."
Goose, a stranger on the Internet says hi to you...
If you want to lose 25 kilograms by June or July, I would say run about 3 to 5 minutes for
every Trump tweet that is extremely detrimental to our world at large.
"How do I nail a phone interview for a real adult job I really want?"
I would say about 30 seconds before the phone interview starts, send a dick pic.
"How do I get my dog to stop hogging the bed?"
Okay, first of all you have to stop calling your Ewok a dog.
That might be why they're a little offended and passive-aggressively stealing half the bed.
"I graduate in December, and I don't know how to decorate my cap! Help!"
Three words for you: hot glue...dildos.
How do you do social media life and IRL so well? It kind of boggles my mind, inspired."
When you are in charge of your social media
you're in control of keeping out the bad.
I'm a full raccoon garbage human, but online I'm only like half.
"How can I start a conversation without being awkward?"
Don't touch the genitals.
Yours or theirs. It's a good start.
"What do you do if a waiter says enjoy your meal, and you say: You too?"
You maintain eye contact with the waiter, no blinking,
start peeing your pants openly, and then throw a smoke bomb
and log-roll your way out of the restaurant.
Okay guys... That's it for this Q & Wednesday.
Let me know in the comments down below any ideas for videos
that I should be doing throughout the month of November
or people that you'd like to see me collaborate with, because I will be collaborating with people,
I'm very excited. Make sure that you are subscribed to this YouTube channel
because hopefully five videos a week will be being produced. *laughs*
We'll see. Other than that. I don't know
"Should I sprint down the street while drunk?" No, you should AT&T down the street
It's only gonna get worse.